[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 14
octobre les titres de ce set 8 journal
ils veulent qu'un rassemblement pour les
élections municipales samedi les ténors
de la droite subie noise ont signé une
charte commune a créé pierre le principe
réunir leurs candidats sous une même
bannière le maire de poissy car le livre
sera en plateau pour en parler projets
et tornado autour de rambouillet
recherche de l'institut vd comme à
versailles satory les expérimentations
du véhicule son chauffeur ont lieu dans
les yvelines et dernier de cire en date
une navette autonome entre la défense et
roissy charles de gaulle développé en
partie au technocentre renault à
guyancourt
enfin un retour sur les résultats
sportifs du week-end et ce match amical
de football guinée comores c'était au
stade mont boron à versailles samedi
cette information pour commencer les
yvelines placer ce soir en alerte orange
aux orages et vents violents par météo
france et l'épisode devrait démarrer à
19h vigilant jusqu'à 23h et de fortes
pluies localisées des rafales de vents
entre 70 et 90 km heure sont attendus
soyez attentif si vous pratiquez des
activités en extérieur la préfecture des
yvelines recommande de limiter vos
déplacements de ne pas se promener en
forêt et d'être aussi attentifs en ville
face aux chutes possibles d'objets
[Musique]
renforcer la position de la droite dans
les yvelines pour les prochaines
élections municipales c'est tout l'enjeu
de la charte rassemblement yvelinois
lancé ce week-end à crêpière plusieurs
principes sont regroupés dans ce
document qui sera soumis aux candidats
les détails avec ce sujet d' or il est
rond et de patrick jacques de dixmude
ils n'ont pas toutes et tous la même
étiquette mais font partie de la même
grande famille politique la droite en
vue des municipales en mars 2000 vingt
sept a créé pierre que ces élus du
département ont signé la charte du
rassemblement yvelinois c'est la
manifestation de l'irrédentisme yvelines
- c'est-à-dire la volonté des élus
yvelinois de refuser des extrêmes
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite et
de se mettre d'accord sur un mode de
gestion sur des objectifs communs et on
veut leur apporter à travers le
rassemblement des chinois une espèce de
maisons communes dans lesquelles ils
peuvent se retrouver une maison commune
qui repose sur 7 piliers
parmi eux l'écologie la lutte contre
l'insécurité l'emploi ou encore les
politiques de solidarité
c'est à la fois nomme une cohésion une
harmonie autour d'eux des élus et les
yvelinois est également un moyen de
trouver les bonnes solutions est à la
fois financière et la foi d' expertise
pour les projets amenés futur et en
s'assurant effectivement de certaines
valeurs que nous partageons
parmi les signataires les républicains
mais aussi libre génération terrain udi
objectif avec cette charte proposer une
alternative en réveillant la droite et
le centre
en les amenant à se rassembler nous
souhaitons préparer et offrir une
alternative aux françaises et aux
français
je pense y a pas un maire de gauche
comme de droite en france une faute pas
que la france gagne il faut qu'on soit
dans cet esprit très largement au dessus
des postures idéologiques dogmatique et
politique qui exècre aujourd'hui les
français
ce document sera soumis aux candidats
des élections municipales qui pourront
s'ils le souhaitent bénéficier du label
rassemblement yvelinois sortir le livre
on vous a vu dans ce sujet vous êtes le
maire de poissy cofondateur de
génération terrain est signataire donc
cette charte pour le rassemblement
yvelinois est d'ailleurs ce
rassemblement qui n'est pas possible au
niveau national vous n'avez pas
renouveler votre adhésion au parti les
républicains valérie pécresse a quitté
le parti l'udps et n'est plus un allié
au niveau national pourquoi ce ce
rassemblement il est possible au niveau
local un peu ce que j'ai dit c'est à
dire que je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
français sont au delà de toutes les
postures dogmatique politique et surtout
on parle de séquence électorale qui est
une municipale qui était exactement
l'antithèse d'étiquette politique est
sur un scrutin de liste pas de scrutin
de partir je dis même pas inscrits en
liste je parle même pas de scrutin liste
je parle d'un rendez vous entre une
femme ou un homme avec ses administrés
et pour être exact au rendez vous il
faut connaître ses administrés donc
faire du terrain et quand on fait du
terrain quand on a une politique de
terrain quand on est dans la démocratie
de proximité
quand on en refait son pain quotidien
alors on a les résultats en 2014 avec
une liste diverses et de personnalités
différentes et d'ailleurs des étiquettes
politiques
elle aussi différente mais homogène aux
services d'un chef de type de film votre
serviteur plutôt issu d'une droite
sociale populaire gaullistes on a été
élu au premier tour avec 62 % et dans la
séquence électorale suivante au
départemental avec 82% sur la ville de
poissy
donc ça fonctionne je le dis et je le
répète il n'ya pas un maire de gauche ou
de france qui ne souhaite pas que la
france gagne je souhaite que mon pays
gagne or deux jours avant cette
signature c'était jeudi vous attribuez
votre votre label génération terrain à
15 candidats aux municipales vous en
faites partie à poissy il ya également
arnaud péricard à saint-germain-en-laye
ce joséphine coleman ce berger à plaisir
vous n'avez pas peur que tout cet
enchevêtrement finalement de la belle ne
perdre les électeurs dont je crois
justement que les électeurs aujourd'hui
veulent pas veulent pas entendre parler
encore une fois je le dis dès posture
dogmatique systématique parce qu'une
idée par exemple que je prends souvent
nob en exemple le dédoublement des
classes de cp ce1 dans les zones
prioritaires
c'est une très belle idée quand on l'est
du style du terrain c'est l'idée de
monsieur blanc kerk ministre d'éducation
de monsieur macron il faut que je ne
sois pas d'accord parce que je suis un
maire de droite et ben si je suis
d'accord et je l'applaudis dès demain en
revanche
typiquement à titre personnel je ne suis
pas favorable sur l'élargissement de la
pma je le dis et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est dire les choses quand ça va ne pas
être d'accord et en expliquant pourquoi
et puis je pense que derrière on est
capables de s'entendre s'ils ont bien
deux sur bien des domaines et bien des
choses
qu'est ce qu'on souhaite pour nos
administrés c'est qu'ils vivent bien
ensemble qui vivent mieux ensemble le
cas échéant c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire au quotidien mais c'est par
exemple le cas d'un arnaud péricard à
saint-germain-en-laye se dire qu'on peut
être à la fois soutenue par la
république en marche avoir le label
génération terrain et rassemblements
yvelinois mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
encore une fois on est dans une démarche
d'ouverture et de et de rassemblement il
se trouve que dans mon équipe
aujourd'hui j'ai des partenaires du
gouvernement avec le modem
j'ai des élus qui sont en marge et des
élus qui sont républicains des élus qui
sont comme moi aujourd'hui sans
étiquette et pour autant ça fonctionne
parce qu'on a la foi et on a le coeur de
poissy c'est ce qu'ils souhaitaient s'il
faut mettre en exergue
lorsqu'on est sur une séquence municipal
savez à chaque jour suffit sa peine
viendra le temps où il faudra se
positionner pour des échéances
nationales
et comme on dit politique mais si on n'a
pas compris que depuis 2010 est il ya
des choses qui sont passés dans le pays
que les codes politiques sont totalement
différents alors on a rien compris il
faut pas s'étonner deux choses 1 qui est
un record d'abstention et 2 que le front
national continue gentiment mais
sûrement à augmenter sa croissance
autre sujet dont je voulais parler avec
vous car le lycée la journée sans poids
lourd poids s'il organise ce jeudi 17 17
octobre
l'accès sera interdit à la ville aux
poids lourds de plus de 3 tonnes 5 des
barrages filtrants mise en place et
c'est la quatrième édition déjà de cette
opération pourquoi la renouveler une
nouvelle fois parce que la circulation
d'un poissy est insupportable elle est
dramatique malheureusement il n'y a pas
de cause à effet il ya bientôt deux
semaines on a eu un drame à poissy
puisqu'une malheureusement une dame est
passée sous un poids-lourd ali a laissé
lille ya laissé sa vie
c'est insupportable aujourd'hui à la
différence d'autres communes c'est que
la ville de poissy est traversé par les
poids lourds elle n'est pas de
contourner par les pommes comme on
l'expliqué la proximité de grands axes
l'a13 l'a14 alex plus long la grêle
explique l explique par le manque de
courage
départ de l'état ensuite d'un certain
nombre de partenaires qui n'ont pas
compris qu'il nous fallait absolument le
bouclage de la francilienne le blocage
de le bouclage de la 104 alors nous on
ne pâtit pas le fait de refuser la
francilienne l'a104 ont pâti au
quotidien d'avoir des poids lourds au
nombre parfois de 2000 par jour qui
traverse la ville de poissy
alors c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui
puisque j'ai pris des arrêtés sur toutes
les voies communales
interdiction de circuler à chaque fois
qu'il ya un contrôle il ya une
verbalisation
je regardais tout à l'heure les
statistiques depuis 2014 c'est 3253
camions qui ont été contrôlés
plus de la moitié 53% qui ont été
verbalisés il faut donner un coup d'épée
c'est pas un coup d'épée dans l'eau
c'est un coup d'épée
c'est un message qu'on envoie il est
ensuite que vous voyez que le trafic se
réduit justement de ces poids lourds sur
l'autre viennent avec ses opérations
alors depuis qu'on a fait ça on a 70 %
de circulation de poids lourds en moins
mais il faut pouvoir continuer et moi ce
que j'aimerais et j'interpelle l'état
sur le sujet c'est qu'on puisse avoir un
élargissement de la police des mers
comme on dit cirque aujourd'hui quand on
verbalise un poids lourd
l'amendé est à 35 euros minorée à 22
euros
si vous payez dans les trois jours
autres autant dire pardonnez moi
l'expression vous pisser dans un violon
si demain comme je le souhaite c'est
entre 500 et 1500 euros
alors là le poids lourd est son
employeur ne passeront pas deux fois
c'est le message que j'entends faire
passer c'est ce que j'ai dit au ministre
le corps nu et à la ministre madame
gourou la semaine dernière le dispositif
pour cette journée qu'elle est il sur la
vidéo possible partir de 9h jusqu'à 11h
contrôle et ensuite tout au long de la
journée avec pas moins de quinze
collègues de la police municipale un
certain nombre d'élus également de
bénévoles puisqu'on est toujours dans la
dans la prévention mais encore une fois
tous les poids lourds de transit seront
amenés à faire demi-tour la ville de
poissy n'est pas une zone de transit où
on vient gagner 30 minutes
en quittant la case d'à côté pour aller
chercher la 13 de l'autre en revanche je
vais terminer là c'est que les poids
lourds qui sont là pour travailler pour
aller livrer et c'est comme chez psa
comme à l'hôpital comme dans deux
entreprises où les commerces il n'y a
pas de difficultés par rapport à sa
quatrième journée sont peu lourd c'est
donc ce jeudi à poissy merci karl olive
maire divers droite de poissy merci
d'être venus en plateau il ya presque un
an 60 mille personnes défilaient dans
plusieurs villes de france contre les
violences et
suis allé sexistes à l'appel d'un
collectif nous tout depuis ce collectif
formé des comités locaux dont un dans
les yvelines qui organisait la semaine
dernière sa deuxième réunion
d'information à trappes en vue de la
prochaine marche marie gagna piceno à
l'heure où nous écrivons ce reportage
120 femmes sont mortes sous les coups de
leur conjoint ou ex conjoint depuis le
1er janvier 2019
parmi ces féminicide quatre se sont
déroulées dans les yvelines
le collectif citoyen nous tout organise
des réunions locales pour sensibiliser
la population
cette réunion c'est à la fois une
réunion de sensibilisation sur les
mécanismes des violences pour que les
gens et les chiffres en tête qui
comprennent un peu mieux comment ces
violences se met en place et c'est aussi
une réunion de mobilisation pour la
grande marche nationale qui aura lieu le
23 novembre
je te crois exemples de phrases a
prononcé à une victime qui viendrait se
confier dans le département elles sont
une quinzaine à prendre le temps de
délivrer ses conseils
une démarche saluée par les
professionnels qui la trouvent
complémentaire à leur travail quotidien
des deux victimes
la question c'est de sensibiliser
l'opinion publique et puis aussi les
professionnels
pas que les gens qui héberge mais les
professionnels les policiers les
gendarmes les juges avec ses lecteurs
les event compte 165 places
d'hébergement pour les femmes victimes
de violences il fait partie des
départements les mieux dotées de france
une douzaine de personnes soucieuses de
ces questions se sont rendus dans ce
local prêté par l'union locale de la cgt
de trappes le message mois que j'ai
retenu c'est que en plus de l'engagement
vraiment nationale des revendications
nationales qui est vraiment des choses
aussi à faire au niveau local et je
trouve que c'est vraiment des actions
d'avenir pour pouvoir agir contre ce
fléau
le collectif s'est donné pour objectif
de réunir cent mille personnes à la
prochaine marche nous tout le 23
novembre avant une page santé avec mon
nouvel invité on parle d'abord de cette
nouvelle étape dans le département avec
les navettes autonome dans les yvelines
à une nouvelle étape pour le
développement de ses navettes la région
ile-de-france le groupe renault et
google ont annoncé vendredi dernier un
partenariat pour développer un réseau de
navettes autonome entre l'art héros à
l'aéroport roissy charles de gaulle et
la défense on en parle avec vous nicolas
landry bonsoir bonsoir le risque de la
rédaction de tv 78 quels ont été les
toners des annonces nicolas et bien
c'était vendredi dernier au technocentre
renault de guyancourt la présidente de
la région ile de france valérie pécresse
et à disability directeur business
développement de l'alliance renault
nissan mitsubishi ont annoncé leur
collaboration avec avoué mot c'est la
filiale de google
leur objectif développer navette
automnaux ne pour relier l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle au quartier de
la défense
et tout cela en passant par l'autoroute
l'un et l'a86 alors ce projet est prévu
pour quand et quels sont les raisons de
son développement
l'idée serait de mettre en place le
service de transport innovant à
l'horizon 2024
vous y pensez c'est les jeux olympiques
aujourd'hui 1500 à 2000 personnes par
jour transitent entre ces deux sites
avec ses navettes autonome l'objectif
est de fluidifier le trafic et faciliter
le transit parce que là il se ferait
directement un projet financé à hauteur
de 100 millions d'euros par la région
ile-de-france écouter valérie pécresse à
ce sujet la région va s'occuper des
infrastructures la région va s'occuper
des infrastructures c'est à dire des
routes pour les aménager
ils mettent des capteurs permettre aussi
avec l'état que l'on puisse rouler sur
les bandes d'arrêt d'urgence est utilisé
ces voies supplémentaires pour faire des
expérimentations d'ici la mise en
service définitive en 2024
alors vous l'avez entendu c'est les
bandes d'arrêt d'urgence qui seront
utilisés les bandes d'arrêt d'urgence de
l'a1 et de l'a86 concernant la navette
est pourrait ressembler à ça les i go un
concept car de renault présenté au salon
de genève en 2018
une navette d'auto partage avec
plusieurs personnes à l'intérieur
la commande pourrait se faire via une
application on pense peut-être à vienne
à vigo un dispositif existant de la
région et un projet qui serait
développée notamment au technocentre
renault de guyancourt sur saint quentin
en yvelines
on a enfin tous les concepts cas qui
sont ici on a comme l'a rappelé madame
la présidente on a beaucoup de dons
intelligence artificielle entre
guillemets ici donc on a des centres
d'essai de simulation donc c'est
vraiment le lieu on peut marier les
différentes expertises nécessaires pour
pouvoir faire aboutir ces concepts là
par contre ça n'empêcherait pas de faire
des expérimentations sur la route
puisque c'est là où l'acceptabilité et
la réalité des objets sera testée alors
voilà pour ce projet nicolas mais il y
en a bien d'autres dans les yvelines
effectivement grégory le véhicule
autonome dans les yvelines a commencé
autour d'une structure cvd com créé en
2012 cet institut de recherche développe
ce type de véhicule sur le plateau de
satory notamment ses deux navettes qui
circulent sur ce site depuis fin 2010 8
elle roule à 15 km heure maximum et sont
reliées à 16 satellites et fonctionne
avec des capteurs appelés les lidar un
de leader sur le toit qui permettent de
détecter les bâtiments on va avoir un
lidar 3d ici un de chaque côté bien
entendu
qui permettent de doc 2 de voir ce qui
se passe sur les côtés et enfin on va
avoir des lidar en bas 4 donc et qui
vont permettre notamment de déclencher
la chaîne de sécurité c'est à dire que
s'il ya une personne qui arrive la
navette arrive autres projets développés
dans les yvelines c'est tornados et à
rambouillet le 8 octobre dernier des
expérimentations été réalisé avec deux
véhicules autonomes sur la voie publique
un projet pour développer un axe de
véhicules autonomes entre le centre
commercial du bel air à rambouillet et
la gare de gaz rend un projet lancé en
2014 et qui pourraient aboutir autour de
2025 sur un axe dédié et sur la route
classique d'ici à 2030
merci nicolas pour ce point
d'information je me tourne à présent
vers mon deuxième invité dans ce journal
c'est pire bézy bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le président de l'ajs beilin
l'association pour le développement des
soins palliatifs on parle avec vous de
ce week end c'était une journée mondiale
qui était organisée des des soins
palliatifs un jour d'action pour
célébrer soutenir l'accompagnement des
malades et à l'occasion de cette journée
mondiale quelques jours avant c'était
jeudi
elle vous organisez une première
rencontre des acteurs pour les soins
palliatifs dans les yvelines c'est à
versailles à la maison de quartier de
porchefontaine déjà juste un élément de
définition qu est ce qu on appelle les
soins palliatifs alors les soins
palliatifs ce sont des soins de qui sont
qui sont donnés à des personnes qui
souffrent de maladies graves de maladies
chroniques ou
en situation terminale la particularité
des soins palliatifs c'est qu'ils sont
multi multi factorielle tout il n'ya pas
que la sphère du soin spécifique mais il
y à aussi bien de deux les psychologues
qui interviennent les kinésithérapeutes
etc
avant la cdu du soin généralisée et à ce
titre là le les accompagnants bénévoles
que nous sommes à la sp yvelines sont
d'ailleurs inscrits dans la loi des
soins palliatifs et ça fait depuis plus
de 20 ans que la sp yvelines accompagne
aux côtés des soignants des personnes
qui sont en maladie grave
la particularité que nous avons c'est
que nous travaillons aux côtés de
soignants sans être soignants ont une
blouse nous n'en avons pas et c'est ce
qui fait toute la différence
parce que nous pouvons de cette position
de bien bien spécifique bien singulière
nous pouvons entendre des choses que les
soignants n'entendent pas forcément
auprès auprès des malades et tous les
synergies finalement à a créé entre ce
monde de la santé est aussi le monde
associatif
cette journée de rencontre c'était une
première dans les yvelines avec les
différents acteurs sur le sujet c'était
important de de la réaliser justement
pour créer peut-être ces synergies ce
que c'était peut-être l'un des objectifs
exactement
c'était l'objectif était de de mettre en
évidence que le les malades qui sont en
soins palliatifs ont beau être l'objet
de beaucoup de soins
il n'en reste pas moins vivant et c'est
un lieu où la vie explose de partout et
donc vivre ça veut dire penser ça veut
dire parler ça veut dire se raconter ça
veut dire aussi imaginer créer et on a
voulu autour de toutes ces thématiques
qui sont vraiment essentiel à une vie
normale autour de toutes ces thématiques
on a rassemblé des innovations qui était
innovante de déployer dans des
associations et on les a présentés au
secteur d'aidé soignant pour essayer de
créer des synergies des rencontres entre
les uns et des autres et qui étaient les
acteurs présents cités les différents
établissements de santé des yvelines les
hôpitaux les maisons de santé peut-être
on avait beaucoup de ce qui faisait très
très plaisir c'est qu'on avait on avait
beaucoup de jeunes en formation à
l'école d'infirmiers et infirmières à
peu près 80 90 personnes dans ce cadre
là on avait eu il restait une
cinquantaine de soignants et puis
quelques bénévoles donc on était quand
même 160 personnes c'est une grande
réussite on est fier mais le bilan c'est
une réussite est ce que des
collaborations pu être créés de douayeul
synergie oui déjà la sortie les cartes
les numéros de téléphone les cartes de
visite chez chance échangés entre les
uns et les autres donc et on va faire
durer cette ce lancement en mettant à
jour régulièrement sur notre site
internet une page qui sera
spécifiquement axé concernant ces accès
activités innovantes possible de mettre
en place dans les équipes soignantes un
mot pour terminer sur votre association
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure d'un mot
important l'accompagnement c'est l'une
des missions principales de la sps est
associé
l'accompagnement c'est la première des
missions accompagner les personnes
malades est trop auprès d'eux pour les
écouter pour leur apporter de la
présence et du soutien en même temps on
forme les nouveaux bénévoles vie entre
deux équipes on a un cadre très précis
très sécurisant pour le confort de tout
le monde et pour toutes les informations
sur cette association je vous invite à
consulter son site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci pierre
visite d'être passé emplettes au
président de la spa yves
une c'est le symbole du liban figurant
sur le drapeau national un cèdre a été
planté samedi dans le parc du domaine de
madame elisabeth à versailles témoignage
de paix d'amitié franco libanaise dans
le département la communauté libanaise
qui représente 150 mille personnes dans
l'hexagone l'événement s'est déroulé en
présence du président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier et du préfet
diw des yvelines jean jacques brot et
aussi de l'ambassadeur du liban en
france et les propos sont recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude chaque c'est
d'en planter en france sur n'importe
quel territoire de france et en
particulier dans un territoire aussi
important aussi prestigieux que le
département des yvelines porte un triple
message un message d'amitié de
fraternité d'abord un message fort
d'enracinement et d'attachement au
territoire et enfin un message spontanée
qui témoigne d'une volonté commune que
nous partageons entre le liban et la
france une volonté de résistance et une
volonté de de majesté et ceux cdh re dan
échappe pas à cette règle mais cèdre du
liban et en premier c'était un emblème
national
il trône majestueusement sur notre
drapeau et cdc des arbres cd témoin des
temps immémoriaux
c'est de la pérennité c'est de l'espoir
cet événement lui célébrait la
citoyenneté européenne est aussi la
mobilité les erasmus day se dérouler en
fin de semaine dernière trois jours pour
faire connaître
erasmus plus et partager ses expériences
en trente ans un million de français ont
pu profiter du programme pour faire un
stage ou partir étudier à l'étranger à
l'occasion de ce rendez-vous la maison
de l'europe des yvelines organisée une
journée à l'hôtel de ville de saint
germain en laye c'était jeudi différents
ateliers et tables rondes proposées pour
notamment faire un retour d'expérience
avec des jeunes élèves dans des lycées
de poissy et saint-germain-en-laye
écouter ces deux témoignages collectés
par nos confrères de radio sensations
alors moi j'étais dans une mairie dans
la mairie d'un petit village
je faisais différents services et puis
j'ai pu découvrir le fonctionnement de
la mairie comment ça se passe etc
c'est une très belle expérience on peut
faire de belles rencontres
moi forcément je partis avec une petite
appréhension mais après ça c'est vite
parti
c'est vrai qu'on part on est autonome on
arrive là bas on est seul on parle pas
la langue à la barrière de la langue
alors durant mon séjour j'ai participé
juste un stage bénévoles en fait donc
j'ai été avec le projet erasmus et
durant mon séjour
bah j'ai travaillé dans une petite
boutique en fait on faisait de la vente
de vêtements dans le but de récolter des
fonds pour les enfants en fin de vie
c'est incroyable à quel point en cinq
semaines
on peut gagner comme ça on est tenu de
donner seul en fait on est seul on a
pris nos professeurs on est tout seul en
famille d'accueil
est on obligé de se forcer en fait à
aller vers l'autre allez on parle sport
dangereux dans ce journal
[Musique]
avec michael et demi d'euros bonsoir
sargos la rédaction de tv 78 retour sur
les résultats sportifs du département ce
week-end et on commence par du football
avec une rencontre internationale
c'est ça c'était la fête dans les
tribunes du stade mob auront de
versailles dans le cadre de la trêve
internationale la guinée et les comores
se sont affrontés ce samedi en match
amical
une rencontre inédite sur cette pelouse
qui a plutôt l'habitude de voir évoluer
des équipes de nationale 3 on écoute le
président du club de verser au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est festif ça fait vraiment plaisir de
voir de voir le stade et les tribunes
pleines et et une ambiance chaleureuse
voilà qui les gens qui viennent
supporter leur sélection ça fait
vraiment c'est vraiment sympa si jouer
en ile de france y joue plutôt souvent
en espagne
en afrique nous semble venu de bruxelles
uniquement pour ce match peindre c'est
la patrie ça n'a pas des prix en après
on importe quelle distance ou veine il
l'a boosté pour la petite histoire les
communs ont longtemps porté sur la plus
petite des marges sur le score de 1 but
à 0 vu le succès rencontré pour cette
affiche la ville de versailles n'exclut
pas d'organiser d'autres rencontres
internationales dans les prochaines
années grégory toujours en football
mickaël il y avait de la coupe de france
ont joué ce week-end le 5e tour et lé
club yvelinois n'ont pas été à la fête
voici s'est incliné à 2 à 0 face à noisy
le sec où il s'incline également sur cet
écart face à adamois château a été sorti
aux tirs au but par mois après un match
spectaculaire ponctuée par un 3 3 seul
versailles échappent à cette journée
noire les versaillais l'emportent 1-0
sur le terrain de courcouronnes genre de
la cité royale connaîtront leur
adversaire ce jeudi à 17 octobre et qui
continue donc une série d'invincibilité
depuis février du rugby pour terminer le
championnat de fédérale 2 les plaisirs
en ont réussi à tenir en échec
gennevillois sur la santé rhin lors de
la 4e journée du championnat
score final 20 partout un résultat qui
permet à plaisir d'occuper la 9e place
sur 12 avec un bilan d'une victoire un
nul et deux défaites depuis le début de
la saison
l'objectif du club reste le maintien à
cette saison on continue à parler de
rugby mais cette fois ci dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 versailles
fait du surplace les joueurs de la cité
royale promu cette année dans cette
division n'ont pu faire mieux que match
nul ce dimanche à domicile contre
vincennes lors de la 4e journée
résultat qui n'arrange pas les verser et
qui pointe actuellement à la 8e place
avec une seule victoire au compteur on
écoute le responsable communication du
club pierre chevènement et sûrement
encore un peu tôt pour pouvoir tirer des
conclusions partant n'a eu que quatre
matches en tout cas on est dans on est
dans la réalisation de ce long de ce que
l'on tente raid c'est que il ya une
vraie différence entre l'onu et régional
de la fédération nationale en état
d'esprit une façon à faire évoluer à
changer merci michael ces informations
et d'autres résultats suivre dans votre
émission le 7-8 sport dans quelques
instants sur tv 78 avant de refermer ce
journal une messe dite sous un chapiteau
400 fidèles et ont assisté samedi au
cirque europe a installé en ce moment
attrape une célébration spéciale et des
numéros d'acrobaties et de diabolo 1
été exécutés pendant des psaumes chantés
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]